alors quoi de beau salut à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines ce week-end c'est les départs
en vacances j'espère qu'il fera plus
beau là où vous allez que là où on est
actuellement là parce qu'il fait pas
magnifiquement beau j'espère que pendant
vos vacances vous allez voir vous
reposer et vous détendre c'est vraiment
important de se reposer de se détendre
mais surtout de se détendre mais aussi
sur poser parce que le repos c'est
important mais la détente aussi c'est
l'avant-dernière météo de la saison donc
profitez de chaque instant c'est
important ce week-end apparemment il y a
des orages ça va donner dans les
chaumières je sais pas si c'est une
expression qui se dit on la garde en
tout cas vraiment content de cet été il
part sur les chapeaux de roue avec tout
cet orage là on adore toute cette pluie
on adore et puis on va voir avec vous du
coup où est-ce que vous partez en
vacances et si je peux me joindre à vous
et s'il y a une piscine à vague je serai
de la partie
vous partez en vacances monsieur oui 15
jours
vous allez où en Bretagne à côté de
Fougères ok ça c'est une plante ça
me reposer pas mal on peut venir
vous allez où vous êtes dans une maison
camping on peut on peut savoir un peu
plus village vacances pas mal piscine il
y a des vagues dans la piscine non je
pense pas je peux faire les vagues
on pose des questions en rapport avec
les vacances vous avez des vacances de
prévues là pour cet été dans un dans un
hôtel un petit camping
va falloir que je cotise ou faux
je pars pas très loin je pars à Chartres
voilà c'est ça
aussi
[Musique]
balader
beaucoup de repos ouais parce que là où
j'habite franchement on peut pas se
reposer il faut du repos il faut du
repos on travaille dur on travaille dur
toute l'année il faut se reposer un peu
voilà donc là les vacances c'est détente
et repos détente et repos et puis
profiter quoi bon repos et bonne détente
ah oui
surtout la détente
au repos
équivalents tous repos quoi
merci on a croisé une collègue qui
cherche des bouquins sur le repos et la
détente surtout sur le repos par contre
quand même la détente mais quand même le
repos
à changer le monde
qui a changé ma vie ok
on garde vous avez des vacances de prévu
monsieur oui allez vous avez une piscine
là-bas ok ça m'intéresse moins pourquoi
revenir avec vous ouais
ouais non mais c'est pour le repos le
repos de quoi la détente de qui vient
mais alors
on va interview
c'est une veste
petit comment comme ça
qui s'occupe des prix peut-être non
[Rires]
je chauffe la piscine
comment via mon être
un peu plus large pour faire chauffer
je dois venir avec mes parents bonnes
[Applaudissements]
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]